welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home has
teased more details through empire
magazine including new looks at doc ock
and peter's hideout and hints at the
multiversal cameos popping up in this
movie but buried beneath all these
headlines was one major clue that i
think strikes at the heart of the deeper
mystery of this film the strangeness of
strange doc och may steal the headline
but the real story is this doc awkward
who missed the memo that winking is
never not creepy it's a very difficult
charge to prove
[Music]
man that jury's gonna fall in love with
you especially when it's to signal a
minor that you're about to help him
violate the laws of nature no wonder why
wong's bouncing he doesn't want to get
subpoenaed after months of head
scratching about what cult doctor
strange just joined finally benedict
cumberbatch revealed new details about
strange's relationship with peter and
like the words of many cultists it
really just brings up more questions so
he told empire there's a shade of the
stark relationship it's not as intimate
to begin with because of how experienced
a superhero he is it's a strange dynamic
and it kind of shifts into something far
more parental and corrective and then it
shifts again huh not as intimate to
begin with judging from the first
trailer strange gives peters the keys to
the freaking sanctum with zero
hesitation way cozier than the hugless
toy snatching strictness stark showed in
homecoming and what's this talk about
shifting now i get to parental and
corrective we hear doctor strange
scolding peter in the trailer but then
these words shifts again how we have
speculated before that doctor strange
may end up shifting to more of an
antagonistic role a villain as peter
shifts to align with some of seeming
villains crossing over into this movie
and ever since some visual details we
saw in the post-credits scene of venom
let there be carnage combined with new
imax trailer details i spotted a few
weeks ago i have been speculating that
doctor strange could actually be under a
spell of his own a spell conjured by
wanda maximoff the scarlet witch while
doctor strange has always been a man of
contradictions with an affinity for rule
breaking and pushing the boundaries of
his mystical abilities just out of
arrogance he has not shown much patience
for avengers who cannot keep up with him
like when he first met peter parker in
infinity war i'm sorry i'm confused as
to the relationship here and what what
is he your ward no i'm peter by the way
doctor strange oh you're using your made
up names i'm spider-man then
the ship is self-correcting its course
when it comes to saving you or the kid
or the time stone
i will not hesitate to let either of you
die now sure end game brought these two
together as the no way home trailer
suggests
so peter
so why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry
to bother you sir please we're safe to
have the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir but striking
up a warm fire sipping from a mug
reading oh for fox's sake as in it's for
fox's sake i'm about to bring the x-men
of the mcu strange oddly
complies with peter's whiny request to
gaslight all of society despite wong
warning him don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
oh for fox's sake indeed strange is
drinking something and it would not
surprise me if it's the same tea wanda
maximoff is brewing in the wanavision
post scene t she is ready to spill in
the multiverse of madness the scarlet
witch has been confirmed for multiverse
of madness since the get-go and one
vision really was conceived as a prelude
series to that event agatha harkness
read from the darkhold that wanda was
destined to overpower doctor strange
your power exceeds that of the sorcerer
supreme the show's producers confirmed
their intention to have doctor strange
cameo as the true origin of the
commercials throughout that series with
ask your doctor for nexus
antidepressants actually referring to
warnings for doctor strange about this
emerging nexus being and then the
post-credits scene featured the scarlet
witch using dr strange's big move an
astral projection spell yet while her
physical body was awake whereas strange
needs to be asleep or incapacitated to
pull this off all while dr strange's
theme music plays
now going this in depth can sometimes
just make my mind really tired which
makes a night of sleep that much more
important but no matter how hard i try
it's just really hard to get my bedroom
completely dark at night like i got
these chargers and alarms power strips
everywhere it's a minefield of
distracting lights brightening up my
room and just making it really hard to
fall asleep but that's where the blue
blocks remedy sleep mask comes in handy
and thanks to blue box for sponsoring
this video we already know blue blocks
from their blue light blocking glasses
but their sleep mask goes further and
blocks out 100 of light so that you can
sleep better it has these adjustable eye
cups and an adjustable strap to get
everyone the perfect fit it works for
folks who sleep on their belly side and
their backs and you can fully open your
eyes while wearing it in no light
anywhere like my eyes are open right now
does that creep you out kind of creeps
me out it's just great for improving
sleep meditation napping and travel you
just pop these bad boys on while flying
and you are gonna be doing great so go
to blueblocks.com
new rockstars or just click the link
below and get 20 off your remedy sleep
mask today the code is automatically
applied for that 20 off so all you need
to do is click the link below and enjoy
free shipping on orders over 115
get the best sleep possible right now
and grab yourself a blue blocks remedy
sleep mask go to b-l-u-b-l-o-x
new rockstars or just click the link
below and get 20 off your order code
automatically apply to check out and i
love how when you re-watch the vfx in
the scene you can see three globes
orbiting the scarlet witch as she floats
there and right as one of those worlds
collides with the darkhold that is the
moment she looks up to hear the voices
of her sons calling out for help it's
not dissimilar to the three rings that
orbit doctor strange as he struck a
similar pose earlier on in that spell
these were bands with distinct writing
on them like separate timeline scripts
that now collide with each other to
bring these separate universes together
these are two multiverse collisions and
i think they are synced both of them
with their strings pulled by the scarlet
witch her physical body wears gray
sweats and bruised tee in a cold
mountainous region while doctor strange
wears gray sweats sips a mug in a
sanctum covered in snow these events are
one in the same linked with the sanctum
sanctorum under the hex spell of the
scarlet witch marionetting him from afar
now we have to look at this wink and i'm
sorry to read into this because no one
should have to stare at someone winking
for this long but in one division winks
were how witches signaled that something
nefarious was afoot agatha winked at us
when she revealed herself in episode
seven but also when she toyed with
vision back in episode three
in episode one after wanda tells vision
she quote has everything under control
which was later of course revealed to be
a double meaning as she and to some
extent agatha controlled vision and all
of westview and wanda has this little
exchange with agnes and elizabeth olsen
doesn't quite pull off a full lucille
bluth wink but the script does
explicitly call for wanda to wink here
now in the let there be carnage post
credit scene eddie brock warps into the
mcu and that reality warp takes the
specific visual of the wallpaper
flipping over like tiles and the
furniture flickering into alternate
decor just like we saw wanda's living
room furniture and wallpaper flickering
in episode 7 and how she jigsawed this
whole home together in episode 8. the
warping of eddie brock's hotel room was
the doing of the scarlet witch who has
the same redecorating style kevin feige
even confirmed collaboration existed
between his marvel studios team and the
let there be carnage team suggesting
even the same designers vfx team could
have overseen these wanda vision hex
reality warps as well as dr strange's
spell in no way home and venom's
multiversal trip so now when we are
seeing increasing set images of multiple
shades of dr strange somewhere his hair
is messy somewhere it's nice and neat
when we now look at this strange who's
just warm and cozy by a fireplace your
friendly neighborhood strange like he's
waving at you from across the picket
fence in west view sheltering in place
with witch's brew and witchy winks who
deceives and sends our most trusted
sorcerer packing i don't think it's that
insane to conclude that the scarlet
witch is destined succession of the
sorcerer's supreme and proven mastery of
his iconic spell reclaiming his theme
music is all evidence pointing to doctor
strange being the latest puppet under
wanda maximoff's spell gladly using
peter parker's request to rewrite
reality as a pretext to collide the
multiverse in pursuit of reality where
her children exist perhaps the origin of
those missing kid posters in the no way
home set photos we saw way back when
giving us a pretty close approximation
of the house of m events we have all
been waiting wanda to step up into the
sorcerer supreme under a spell by the
scarlet witch a nexus bean desperate to
rewrite reality using any excuse she can
and any other sorcerer she can to try to
get her kids back carry back my sons now
i don't know if that is a cryptic shift
cumberbatch was referring to or if this
will be explicitly stated in no way home
or in his post-credit scene but with
wanda's confirmed takeover and
multiverse of madness the seance table
is set you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching
bye
[Music]
you